candlelighters is a local charity that
steps in
financially and emotionally to help
families with a child
battling cancer for the first time in 31
years
they held their annual superhero 5k
virtually
but they had a little extra help well
the goal was to
motivate a lot of people who was running
the student council kids at tarkanian
middle school
took a break from distance learning and
looked for a way to lend a hand
this was just such a great time for us
to come together
live and not virtually and do something
for our community
knock out childhood cancer spread that
message of awareness
the kids logged off zoom and headed out
chalk in hand
to decorate the three-mile race route
with inspiring messages
words of encouragement and the vivid
logo of superman
and the hulk smash i really feel like it
helped all the runners
stay motivated and keep going it meant
the world to the candlelighters team to
have support from students
whose sole purpose was simply to spread
love
tarkanian middle school's involvement
was just so special for us
you know kids helping kids fight cancer
there's nothing more positive than that
for the tarkanian kids it was about
community
but also connection they got to see
their buddies but the best part was
being able to see each other
at the same time social distance and you
know just inspire
the runners and keep them going and
that's what's cool at school
home edition and we want to hear more
about the positive things happening
during distance learning right now
send us your ideas send them to brian
email cool at school
eight newsnow dot com and we will share
those stories every week right here on
channel eight that is so cool to see
john i love that
excellent work by those kids certainly
it's harder to do some things because of
the pandemic but it never hurts to be
nice
and that's something those kids are
doing great job at